joining me now is Chris Bedford
executive editor for the common sense
society and Ari Fleischer former White
House Press Secretary and Fox News
contributor Ari Butler's team told the
angle in part that she's been a
California homeowner since 2011 in
addition to her home Ms Butler has
another place in La where she will be
residing
so many homes so many choices
let's just stipulate it doesn't matter
when you're in California and you're a
Democrat you can do whatever you want
now as for her residency it's
interesting to me none of the four
people mentioned for extended candidacy
her now serving appointed by the
governor and the three Democrats running
none of them none of the four were born
in California now at least Adam Schiff
and Barbara Lee moved there as children
and they both went to college there so
I'm kind of curious if Schiff and Lee
are going to make it an issue against
her if she decides to run in 2024 that
Butler is not really a Californian she
moved there later in life and then moved
away and so she's a ping pong ball now
she's back
Chris you know this is something I'm
envious of of Gavin Newsom and the
Democrats right now I wish Republicans
could take a lesson on just how vicious
this is I mean Senator Dianne
Feinstein's been dead for 24 hours and
they appoint a black lesbian who's
devoted her life to killing babies in
the womb so say what you will about the
Democratic governor they they please
their constituents they take care of
their voters they take care of the
people get the money you look at
Republicans what do we get uh Luther
strange I mean Kelly loffler these are
the kind of people that Republican
Governors give to their candidates as
when they select a candidate Newsome
doesn't even care if she's from
California or not he gives the base what
he wants he rewards them and he doesn't
hold them in contempt like their GOP
does all the time well all right
said about Republicans this was last
year on the issue of abortion watch
assistant is that they are determined to
take away freedom from people in this
country to make decisions about their
own body and to ensure that they
themselves elected officials have the
power and control uh to make decisions
for every woman in this country
Ari um she's just a rank partisan
radical perfect for California it's a
shock that 500 000 people have left
there yeah isn't that exactly right
Laura you know if you're a U.S senator
you need to wait two years before you
can become a lobbyist but now we have a
lobbyist who can immediately become a
California Senator
and in this case you have somebody who's
a lobbyist who believes in abortion
right up to the day before the hour
before birth I mean that's what EMILY's
List does the group that she ran they
are the most radical of the pro-abortion
groups that are out there but that's in
tune with the modern day Democratic
party so marry abortion politics to
Identity politics and you get
California's new Senator Butler Chris
Bedford I we I want to talk about
something we touched on last week was
this possibility that Democrats because
they're in such a hole on the border
question that there would be some
movement or some perhaps policy tweak on
the part of Biden that they could point
to is oh we're hearing you we're
addressing the problem and yesterday I
believe it was yesterday
um hokel spoke out and I want to play
this sound bite about what Democrats are
doing on immigration
we want them to have a limit on who can
come across the border it is too open
right now and that is a real problem for
New York City 125
000 newly arrived individuals and we are
being taxed
Chris I mean they can't they can't take
anymore they say they want to go all the
South Dakota North Dakota Montana all
the red States yeah what they meant that
she would famously quote our infamously
quoted Emma lazarus's poem at the bottom
of the Statue of Liberty just a short
while ago saying that New York is open
and what she meant by give us your poor
and you're hungry she meant give Texas
your poor and your hunger give Arizona
give New Mexico give anyone except for
us now illegal immigration is an easy
thing to stand in the soapbox about and
to say this is the right thing this is
what our nation was built on et cetera
et cetera but it's much more difficult
than the reality On the Border that's
right when you had Elon Musk going down
there and actually just live streaming
from the border you heard reporters from
other networks saying how dare he go
down there what do you mean how dare he
he's a citizen and people are lying
about what's going on there the reality
is being felt New York I just on the way
into the studio today there was an
obvious bicycle a biker gang hanging out
of what used to be the DC homeless
shelter clearly all new illegal
immigrants say the the whole face of the
city in that area is starting to change
even in Washington DC and now it's being
felt in these places and but the people
I think are now making their voices
heard and Ari you know maybe a few years
ago folks didn't think this was going to
Bubble Up to become one of the seminal
issues of 2024 but I think that's
changed I think people feel the change I
think people don't want it and they said
we didn't vote for it this is not with
what we is not what we thought I mean
meaning kind of mainstream Democrat
voters that they were going to get when
they voted for Biden and actually Laura
you of course you were at the Forefront
of that you were one of the people who
did see that very early in a Republican
party that was changing on this issue
and it's it's absolutely right it's a
moral issue I mean either we are a
nation of laws with Borders or we're not
and the Democrats have lost the ability
to make a moral distinction between
someone who comes here illegally and
legally to them it doesn't matter to
most Americans it does matter and that's
why this is a Salient issue eight
million people probably more like 13 or
14 million people who've come in Chris
quickly Gates challenging McCarthy for
the speakership Newt Gingrich push back
really hard over the weekend on social
media saying this is a
self-inflicted wound on the part of the
Republican Party agreeing with Gates on
the spending issue but saying you don't
have the votes yet so what is this going
to ultimately accomplish your view I'm
not too sure it's going to accomplish
that much I mean there's a lot of real
principled opposition to McCarthy you
want to listen to that you go to someone
like chip Roy what's going on between
McCarthy and Gage at this point seems
like a personal Grudge Ari thoughts on
that quick yeah I think it's nihilistic
I just don't know what they seek to
accomplish and whoever it is going to be
the next speaker they're going to try to
vacate that person anybody who has to
make any agreement or compromise they're
against you can't vote with a five vote
majority and speak like you have a 50
vote majority Republicans only have five
you have to have more votes you have to
get you have to get power back and until
you get the votes you can't make a lot
of these seminal seminal decisions Ari
and Chris thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else